vamos a ver si podemos resolver este
problema dice arturo va a construir tres
estantes para su padre él tiene un
pedazo de madera de 12 pies de largo del
cual quiere que el estante superior sea
medio pie más pequeño que el estante de
enmedio déjame tomar colores para que
poco a poco vayamos utilizando los datos
del cual déjenme agarrar otro color
quiere que el estante superior sea medio
bien más pequeño que el estante de en
medio muy bien este es otro dato y con
otro color voy a poner que el estante
inferior sea medio bien más pequeño que
2 veces la longitud del estante superior
y bueno lo que nos dice la pregunta es
lo siguiente si altura quiere usar los
12 pies de madera que tienen cuanto debe
de medir cada estante muy bien ya
tenemos aquí el problema ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es definir variables como
necesitamos saber la longitud de
nuestros tres estantes uno superior uno
en medium uno inferior entonces vamos a
ponerles nombre ahora lo primero que voy
a hacer es definir variables voy a decir
que t es la longitud del estante
superior
la longitud del estante superior que m
es la longitud del estante de en medium
m es la longitud del estante de enmedio
la longitud del estante de enmedio ya
tengo el superior ya tengo el del medio
y por último que es la longitud del
estante inferior ve va a ser el estante
inferior del estante inferior y bueno
que me dicen estos datos el primer dato
lo podemos escribir en matemáticas de la
forma siguiente dice arturo quiere que
el estante superior sea medio pie más
pequeño que el estante de enmedio esto
quiere decir que te tiene que ser igual
al estante de enmedio que es n menos
medio pie porque tiene que ser más
pequeño que el estante en medio entonces
este es igual a m menos un medio o 0.5
muy bien después el siguiente dato me
dice lo siguiente
arturo también quiere que el stand
inferior sea medio pie más pequeño que
dos veces de longitud del estante
superior es decir que el estante
inferior
debe ser medio pie más pequeño que dos
veces la longitud del estante superior
dos veces la longitud del estante
superior es lo mismo que tomarme la
longitud del estante superior que stem y
multiplicarlo por dos porque van a ser
dos veces esa longitud entonces me
quedaría que b es igual a 2 tm menos
medio bien es decir menos un medio muy
bien entonces ya tenemos que el estante
superior se añadió pies más pequeño que
el estante en medio eso quiere decir que
es igual a emen - un medio y después que
el estante inferior sea medio pie más
pequeño que dos veces la longitud del
estante superior eso quiere decir que
vean es igual a 2 t menos un medio ahora
nos falta una ecuación y la última
ecuación la voy a sacar de que dice que
arturo va a usar los 12 pies de madera
completos y por lo tanto con estos 12
pies de madera tiene que
los tres estantes es superior el del
medio y el inferior es decir qué temas
me ven esto tiene que ser igual a 12 a
12 pies muy bien y llevar aquí ya
tenemos las tres situaciones como
resolvemos este problema y bueno amigo
que se me ocurre es poner todo en
términos de m
porque aquí dice que teme es igual a m
un medio entonces voy a usar esta
ecuación de aquí para que cada vez que
yo veo una te ponga en lugar de 3 m
menos un medio por lo tanto aquí tengo
que ver es igual a 2 t menos un medio
pero en lugar de te voy a poner m menos
un medio lo que voy a hacer es una
sustitución entonces en lugar de te voy
a poner en menos un medio y entonces que
me quedaría deben b sería igual a 2 por
tim es decir 2 por m menos un medio
porque recuerda que te vale igual a emen
- un medio entonces 2 por m menos un
medio ya esto le vamos a quitar menos un
medio muy bien y esto que me queda nos
va a quedar 2
por m2m y después dos por menos un medio
entonces b es igual a 2m menos dos por
un medio dos por uno medios uno entonces
menos uno menos un medio o dicho otra
manera b es igual a 2m menos tres medios
menos uno menos un medio es lo mismo que
menos tres medios entonces a esto le
quitamos tres medios y entonces ya tengo
que te es igual a m
un medio que es igual a doce menos tres
medios entonces porque no sustituyó en
esta ecuación su ataque tenemos aquí el
valor de t y el valor de ven en términos
de m y me va a quedar que tm es decir en
menos un medio más m más ven pero en
lugar de b recuerda que voy a poner 2 m
tres medios vamos a usar también esta
otra ecuación que tengo aquí entonces
tengo que ver es igualdad 2 m
tres medios y me va a quedar m - un
medio más n más 2 m menos tres medios
esto es lo que vale ven esto tiene que
ser igual a 12
es ya tengo una ecuación con solamente
una incógnita no pasa de tener una
ecuación con tres incógnitas a tener una
ecuación con solamente una incógnita
después de que sustituir el valor de t y
el valor debe ahora si tengo una m 12m
es más 2 m son 4 m totales 4 m ya esto
le tengo que quitar menos un medio menos
tres medios menos un medio menos tres
medios son menos cuatro medios lo cual
es menos 2 entonces menos un medio menos
3 medios esto todo esto se reduce a
menos 24 m menos 2
esto tiene que ser igual a 12 y ahora sí
de aquí está muy fácil despejar para n
porque si lo que queremos hacer es
obtener el valor de m primero hay que
sumar dos de ambos lados de la ecuación
de tal manera que si yo tomo otro color
y aquí sumo dos y aquí también sumó dos
entonces que me va a quedar del lado
izquierdo me queda 4 m porque estos dos
se van y del lado derecho me queda 12
más 2 lo cual es 14 y ahora he vivido
todo entre
voy a obtener el valor de m todo entre 4
todo entre 4 y me va a quedar que m es
igual a 14 cuartos pero 14 cuartos es lo
mismo que 7 medios entonces siete medios
m vale 7 medios y al menos ya sé cuál es
la longitud en pies que debe tener el
estante de enmedio el estante en medio
debe tener siete medios de pies de
longitud y bueno ya que se m ahora con
un saco tema pues este es lo mismo que
en menos un medio es decir siete medios
menos un medio lo cual por cierto es
seis medios que es tres el estante
superior debe de medir tres pies su
longitud debe ser tres pies y bueno ya
tengo m que por cierto siete medios es
exactamente lo mismo que tres enteros un
medio de ejemplo aquí es lo mismo que
siete medios o tres enteros un medio de
pies y bueno ya tengo m ya tengo a tema
puede aquí obtener el valor de p pues si
es igual a dos de menos un medio es
decir dos por tres menos un medio lo
cuales seis menos un medio lo cual son
cinco enteros
la longitud del estante inferior debe de
ser de 5 pies y medio 10 más hasta lo
podemos verificar porque 5 un medio más
3 enteros un medio es lo mismo que 9 y 9
312 y por otra parte el estante superior
es medio bien más pequeño que el estante
del medio que era justo uno de los datos
y después obtenemos que el estante
inferiores me dio pie más pequeño que
todos veces el restante superior